We're going to sketch out a solution that uses a similar logarithmic structure to the previous problem.
I'm going to write it in a different way, though, and I'm going to use a table here.
So recall in the previous algorithm,
we began with each node knowing its neighbor 1 hop away.
In the first step, each node learned the node that was 2 hops away.
Then in the next step, 4 hops away and so on.
So we're going to try to use a similar approach here,
and the algorithm's going to proceed in 2 phases.
The first phase is filling in this table, so that every node knows the nodes that are 1, 2, 4, and 8 hops away,
and this if functionally equivalent to find the last element in the link list problem that we just saw,
except that now we're treating a list of circulars so we wrap around.
So at each step of this phase, we're going to begin by knowing the node that's K hops away;
for instance, K equals 1.
And then we're going to compute per node,
the node that is 2 K hops away.
So let's begin. Every node is going to start by knowing the idea of a node that's exactly 1 hop away.